Joining me as an evolutionary biologist,
formerly of Evergreen State University who is now a professional professor in
exile.
Heather.
Hi and welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you for having me.
Days professor and exile.
I believe that is in your Twitter bio.
It is.
I believe it is in your husband,
Bret Weinstein's Twitter bio.
Yeah,
we generated just to get together.
Is that going to be the title of the Co authored a book when the dust settles on
all of this stuff?
Oh,
I dunno.
Um,
I think both of us are both eager to leave the evergreen story behind,
but still heartbroken that an institution that we loved and still believe in the
educational model that it offered and still believe in the students who got
great educations there for many decades.
We,
we would love to see it resurrected,
but it doesn't look like it's going to happen.
Yeah.
All right,
so this is,
it's a little crazy to me that this is the first time that we've met because
obviously our,
our circles have been sort of a closing in on each other for,
for quite some time.
So when,
when the whole evergreen thing happened and I only want to spend a little bit of
time at the top talking about it and then I want to do all sorts of evolutionary
biology stuff.
And the other,
the other things that you're really passionate about,
the story obviously was more focused on Brett and then he was sort of thrust
into the media and all that.
But this was a direct um,
attack on you as well in the end as you said,
the institution that you loved and all that.
Can you just give me any sort of recap or just pieces of it that maybe we don't
know that whether or just your perspective on what was happening there?
Well,
um,
as,
as briefly as I can [inaudible] leaving out many,
many relevant pieces.
We've got a new president and the new president very quickly got rid of a
provost who was going to get in his way and spoke publicly about his desire to
turn evergreen into the social justice college.
That was actually on the record early in George Burgess tenure at the point that
the protests broke out a year ago.
Now Ish.
Uh,
he had been president for about two years and a year before that had broken out
in equity,
uh,
a desire to bring equity and inclusion to the forefront,
which is,
which is code words,
it's dog whistles for the people on the far left who are actually interested in
a reversal of power,
not an end to oppression,
but an actual,
a reversal of historical oppression.
Did,
did you guys recognize those things as Doug Wilson was at the time?
Because as Brett said,
Yup.
At the time he considers himself,
or at least at that time,
did consider himself deeply progressive.
You just said to me right before we started,
you still consider yourself progressive.
Yep.
So did you realize those buzzwords words and what they actually meant at the
time?
Absolutely.
Uh,
I mean,
Brett,
actually I was on sabbatical the year most of the year before this broke out as
part of why I was sort of disappeared from the story I said,
as I went on to sabbatical,
Brett,
I will continue to read everything you want to send out to these lists,
but I'm not engaging.
I'm doing my own work now.
Um,
so about a year,
actually a year to the day before the protest broke out,
the first announcement of the new plan came,
came live,
and then on there and for the next year,
Brett was,
I was a little bit,
a couple of other people were a little bit standing up and saying,
this doesn't smell right.
This,
this feels like this is actually about something that we're not talking about.
And furthermore,
if we're actually interested in improving the fate of various demographic
groups,
these processes are not going to be the way to accomplish them.
So we were saying that,
um,
Brett mostly was saying that a few others of us were saying it.
And,
um,
was there any,
sort of understanding of that point of view privately?
Yes.
Yeah.
Privately,
yes.
People were scared and when in fact,
when Brett used the phrase culture of fear on campus,
what came back at him was you have to prove that there's a culture of fear or
else there's not one.
And,
you know,
show me the people who aren't standing up or else I will know that they,
they don't exist,
which is,
you know,
it's baffling.
Yeah,
right.
It's,
it is obviously an approval,
an unprovable statement to say there's a culture of fear and I'm not going to
out the people who have come to me and told me they're scared because I actually
am going to honor their privacy.
But if,
if everyone who would come to us privately and said this is nuts and it's got to
stop,
had stood up,
it would've been a totally different outcome.
Well,
that's the culture of fear summed up right there.
Right.
Um,
okay,
so without rehashing the whole thing,
can you just tell me a little,
just a little bit about sort of how your life has changed throughout this and
sort of,
you know,
look,
you and Brett,
you guys did settle.
Uh,
it wasn't for a ton of money,
at least in my humble estimation,
but I think you probably want it to just put some of this behind you,
but you guys are professors in exile.
You if you have kids and family and all that stuff and just sort of sum up kind
of where you're at at the moment.
Yeah,
so I mean we had um,
we'd been living in Olympia for 15 years.
Um,
the,
the college was an amazing place to really do a deep dive in community with
students.
And so,
you know,
Brad and I had done one and I had done several long study abroad trips and
Panama and in Ecuador with pretty large groups of undergraduates taking them
through the Amazon,
the Galapagos,
we spent time in the field in Washington state and the San Juans and eastern
Washington.
You took people places where not only were we studying evolutionary biology and
animal behavior and field techniques and Statistics and philosophy of science,
but also coming to know each other such that after,
after you break bread with people for days and you play ultimate with them and
you sit around a campfire,
you come to understand that when they disagree with you,
it's not inherently coming from a place of hatred or personal animosity.
And so that trust that we were able to create in our classrooms,
which both of us love to doing,
allowed us to effectively then rip the intellectual rug out from under people
when they made claims that weren't falsifiable or couldn't be,
couldn't be justified once you started to ask them what the assumptions were
there were underlying their claims.
That was,
that was an amazing gift.
And I don't know that really almost any other educational model out there allows
for that because it required the time to build community with students,
which was,
which was wonderful.
So yes,
we lost two tenure track jobs along with your health insurance and our
retirement plans and all of that and have two kids still in school.
So that's alarming.
But some of what we were doing in the classroom,
we have begun to do on larger stages.
And that is promising.
It seems clear that the world is interested in hearing how to understand systems
from an evolutionary perspective.
I knew that was true from the 25 or 50 students that I had doing the deep dive
for every quarter,
every year for years.
Uh,
it's not that surprising,
but it is heartening to see that that is the response of many,
many people out there.
Weird way.
Does it almost feel right then that this happened?
I mean,
I know it's kind of sucky and again with the salaries and tenure track positions
and all that,
but that the message that you guys are talking about seemed so relevant right
now.
You guys are now doing more public speaking gigs.
I'm,
I'm dragging bread on stage with me to do stand up.
I mean all sorts of crazy things are presenting themselves and then the sort of
the rise of this new alliance of whether you want to call it intellectual dark
web or whatever you want to call it at this point.
But there,
there is this sort of interesting crew of people with a lot of different
feelings on a lot of different issues with all sorts of different disciplines
coming together.
And maybe if you guys were still at university in a traditional sense,
you wouldn't be able to be dealt in the way that
you are now.
I think that's possible.
I think,
um,
there is both a way in which having gone through the looking glass,
having gone through the direct,
you know,
to borrow a phrase from the far left,
but the lived experience of actually being at the center of a mob at the center
of riots and then watching as the world,
the mainstream media and others tried to do a public rate relational spin on it
and tell a totally different story to live that and to watch the institution
that you loved become totally disloyal to you and to watch many people whom you
respected,
um,
hide.
You can't see that it's valuable.
And the fact that we're sitting here talking together and that many of us in,
you know,
the intellectual dark web and,
and this and this bigger group are,
are speaking and saying actually the culture of fear that is society wide is
real.
And so also the,
the first time I met my students after the November,
2016 election after Trump was elected evergreen,
it's a very left place.
Olympia is a very left place.
Pretty much everyone on campus had that glazed eyes.
Slack Jawed looks at people and most progressive enclaves will be familiar with
from that time,
from those few days,
right.
Myself included,
even though it was no Hillary fan,
but I didn't see that outcome coming and I certainly didn't vote for Trump.
I,
um,
we got to class and my co faculty whom I admire greatly,
uh,
just proceeded with her lecture on horse evolution.
And I'm looking around the classroom going,
no one here cares about horsepower.
Today's not a good day.
Day is not the day.
Yeah.
Um,
so she ended up at early and we had lab couple hours later and before she let
them go,
I said,
hold on,
if anyone wants to stay,
this is no longer class.
But if anyone wants to stay,
I would be happy to lead a conversation about what just happened,
what just happened to our country.
And about 40 of our 50 students stayed and skip their lunch hour.
And then we went right to anatomy lab that afternoon from,
from this conversation.
And what I said to them was,
do not for a minute believe that racist and sexist elected Trump.
Think about how many times you have had to censor yourself on this campus when
you had an opinion that was even slightly different from the accepted dogma.
And that conversation not only brought life to the room,
but afterwards I had several students come up to me,
some of them in tears telling me stories about,
one of them had lost a job on campus for speaking in opinion that was not
accepted.
One of them had an another story of another friend who lost a job.
Others talked about their self censorship and um,
that and all of these people,
again,
we're far left.
Not that it should matter,
but these weren't even people who are conservatives who held conservative views.
So that,
that is the larger culture of fear that is hardly restricted to evergreen,
but is society wide that we are,
that we are speaking about and that people are responding to because in,
you know,
at Google,
at Starbucks,
yeah.
It in cubicles in campuses,
but far beyond campuses across the country and across the weird country is at
least this is a problem.
Well,
the irony too
me is that I think that all that I'm doing is talking about these things often
with people who have a much better pedigree than I do.
But by me talking about it,
it's giving room for other people to talk about and that's all that they want.
Well,
you're also,
you were also so
providing ways into the conversation.
I think.
So there are a lot of people when confronted with,
you're not allowed to think that say,
Oh God,
I'm not actually sure how to respond.
I haven't,
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't have the linguistic skills.
I don't have the analytics behind me.
I don't know what I'm supposed to say here.
And so just listening to,
to you and to Sam Harrison,
to Jordan Peterson into Brett and to Eric into me,
um,
and to,
you know,
many,
many others I believe begins to give people a sense of not only is this doable,
these are good,
reasonable,
smart people who are being respectful in what they're saying.
But also it's not just tools.
It's actually like phrases.
It's like,
Yo,
this is what you can say.
These are the things that sort of things that you can say in response that are
still respectful and don't reject the humanity of the person on the other side
but do reject the argument.
It's interesting,
it almost shows that
what you guys obviously were doing so well at a university level,
that's exactly what's needed at a societal level.
Now talking about the language,
the language to get these ideas across,
right is so important.
I wonder is there a evolutionary explanation for a little bit of what has
happened here with the left?
Like the way they've sort of closed off ranks and then purge everyone cause it
was just as I sit here with you,
it's like the idea that you inbred wouldn't be enough of whatever it is that
they want is so bananas and yet it is true.
So is there some way that you can explain that coming from the discipline you
come from?
Well there's,
I think this is not going to be a particularly deep point,
but it's,
it's basic ingroup outgroup dynamics and we will always,
we will not get rid of,
of tribal thinking.
We will not get rid of our sense of,
you know,
you and I are aligned.
Right.
That's,
that's a good thing.
There's a way in which there's a kind of tribalism there,
even though we just met for the first time today.
Yeah.
And we definitely have political differences,
I'm sure,
which we can talk about if we want.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
and,
but,
but that isn't the main thing.
Like we are aligned and I,
you know,
I feel walking in here like you've got my back and you've got my back.
And,
um,
I think people especially raised without much experience with the physical world
and raised often in situations where they're being given a number of
pharmaceuticals early on that are disrupting development,
arrive at what should be the cusp of adulthood and aren't sure how to navigate,
aren't sure how to navigate the waters.
And so when trolled,
Oh,
if you just agree with everything,
if you just become an idea log and go in lock step with us,
you can be with us.
So,
you know,
identity politics is appealing because it provides an instant in group if you
will only subjugate yourself.
Yeah.
And you know,
identity politics on the side begets at any politics on this side of course,
because anyone who shows up here and is told no,
you don't have enough of what the progressive stack tells us you need,
either you can totally subjugate yourself or go over there and we'll,
of course we're going to get a rise over here and back and forth.
W when people criticize us,
whoever this is for not focusing on that identity politics enough,
the one that,
the secondary one that you're talking about here,
which is the identity politics of the right,
which is either you,
which is based in actual racism or,
or you know,
there's a white ethno state or ideas that are so the antithesis of the American
experiment is,
to me they're,
they're ridiculous and have no real,
real world traction.
It's almost like we've created this boogie man cause we need it since been
displaying w no,
no.
Almost no one thinks that way anymore.
Sorry.
No.
Well,
so what's your,
what's your best argument against that?
When people say,
well you're not focusing on that enough because,
because everyone wants everything to be equal all the time.
So if you're focusing on the identity politics of the left,
which clearly many of us see as,
I mean I truly see it.
I,
I've been saying,
listen,
I really believe this.
I view it as the greatest existential threat to western democracy that there is.
I believe that if there's something that would cause us to,
to be on the streets like killing each other,
I think it's that we're,
we'll have broken off and all of the commonalities will,
will disappear.
But what,
what do you think is the best argument for why you're not focusing on that one
enough?
Cause I see that a lot now,
right?
I think,
I think two things.
One,
it's not as big a group,
right?
The,
the,
the white nationalists to the extent that they exist and they do are better
armed by and large than,
than the far left.
But numerically they just don't exist in the same numbers and they don't have
the kind of play,
they don't have the kind of cultural reach that the far left does.
And so that's the second,
well I guess there's three points.
A secondary point then is everyone can walk white nationalists that is
completely acceptable and in fact demanded that you do when those sorts of ideas
come up in conversation.
Whereas the stuff on the far left,
increasingly it is demanded that you not,
so there is,
that's the key right there.
Right?
So like we are saying,
no actually we must,
we must disagree with this just as much as we should.
Just as much as culturally we now know it's a norm to disagree with what's on
the right,
the far right.
It should become a cultural norm to disagree with frankly the cryptic racism and
sexism and you know,
and everything else that's happening on the far left.
It is,
it comes packaged as if it's anti racist and anti sexist and all.
It's just,
it's racist and sexist against the other group.
It's a flipping of the tables of oppression.
So I would say the third point is,
for me anyway,
as someone who has been on the left my whole life,
uh,
this has changed.
This experience is going through the looking glass in the last year has not
changed my values,
but it has changed what I understand about how people are using language to make
other people out to be things they're not.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
I no longer believe in a massive outright,
for instance.
Right,
right.
Um,
and you know,
the,
the bogeyman that are out there that you're not supposed to do things like talk
to Fox News,
sorry.
No,
actually we should all be exposing ourselves to too,
the media across the entire range.
And for me on the left,
it's actually my job much more so than to go after people who I have nothing in
common with,
to go after the people who claim to have values that are similar to mine.
But I see that they are actually achieving goals.
Yeah.
And that's why I love this conversation and don't get tired of it because we're
all in on it at different levels.
We all have different realizations at different times along the timeline and
it's like for me,
I,
that's where I free for two years.
I kept saying I'm of the left and that's why I want to fix this.
I don't think realistically anymore.
I can honestly say that I think I have more in common,
certainly with Libertarians and I find I find an intellectual openness with
conservatives that I just don't find any more on this other side,
and I know there's,
again,
I know there's some people you just spoke at Hetero docs,
you just spoken heterodox.
Jonathan hates being on the show.
I think he's doing wonderful work.
There's obviously people like Brett and like Eric and and Steven pinker and
plenty and Sam and plenty of other that exist still as sort of a same left,
but I see that just being whittled and whittled and whittled away and that
doesn't mean the fights not worth taking it.
Maybe it means it's the most worthy fight,
but I just see it as like an increasingly untenable position to hold.
I see.
I think,
I think there are actually many,
many,
many people out there who are not,
who don't have public platforms,
who are waiting,
who've been waiting for this,
who are watching your,
most of these people would consider this almost themselves Democrats as I always
did.
I don't,
I don't want to identify as a Democrat anymore given what they know stand for.
Uh,
but most I think that,
and this,
you know,
as evidenced by my inbox.
So it's anecdotal,
but it's a lot of anecdotes and you know,
and also my Twitter feed,
uh,
that there are a massive number of people out there who are on the left who have
values on the left and who find no one out there who was making sense except
now,
except this crew of knackered.
Yeah.
And it,
it has taken,
it has taken this to,
you have this fever pitch that we have arrived at a for a number of people.
I really think,
and like I said,
you know,
Google,
Starbucks,
but it's not just those big stories.
There are people writing to me and to Brett from just average workplaces saying,
I'm in fear for my job because I cannot speak anything that doesn't fit the
dogma.
We just hired an equity advisor.
We've just hired an inclusion advisor and it's,
and it's hateful.
It's hateful rhetoric that we are being told to adopt.
This is what's happening across corporate America.
Now.
Of course,
most Americans are not going to appreciate that.
Yeah.
It's like it existed at the universities for a long time.
And finally it started bubbling out of there and those kids took those ideas and
started entering the workforce.
That's why it's so weird.
You know,
people say you're all,
you're focusing on college students too much,
and it's like you do realize they get out of college.
That's usually right.
If there's,
if there's supposed to be.
So tell me a little bit more about sort of what you're doing now.
I know you just spoke at Heterodox and,
uh,
or let's start,
let's start with that
heterodox.
Yeah.
Well,
the,
this was Heterodox Academy's first conference.
Uh,
they and fire are really at the forefront institutionally of,
uh,
defending viewpoint diversity campuses.
A fire from sort of more of a legal perspective and Heterodox at the faculty and
administrative perspective.
And it was point,
it was an intense conference is the only conference I've ever been to where I
thought they should have been longer.
I wanted to be the logger.
It was a daisy all academics in the audience as well or do they open that up?
I think the public,
I think there were probably non-academics there.
I know that there were a lot of journalists there.
Uh,
and most everyone I met were students or faculty or Admin,
um,
or journalists.
Uh,
so I don't know,
I don't know what the,
what the entry rules where,
um,
but you know,
the panels were as,
as John's on heights and at the end of the day,
I,
Jonathan Count only three people who are on the panels of I guess 28 people who
might be conservative.
So he himself pointed out,
you know,
we're striving for viewpoint diversity,
but the fact is,
it's an uphill battle.
You know,
we're not going to get,
just,
just like we shouldn't expect a 50,
56 ratio among software,
software engineers,
between men and women.
We're not going to get a 50,
50 ratio of liberals and conservatives on college campuses.
It's not necessarily the kind of work that conservatives flock to in the same
numbers as liberals.
So I think,
you know,
we need to be careful about imagining what,
what equity would look like as in all of these arguments.
At an ideal level,
why would it be that conservatives would be less inclined to be doing academics?
I guess it depends on what our definition of conservative is.
One of,
um,
a stereotype that comes to mind that I may regret saying is that a liberal types
take some odd pride and not caring about making a good living,
making good money in faculty positions tend to tend to fit that right.
Certainly Evergreen did.
Um,
so you know,
if you,
if what if one of your primary goals is not only to make a good living for
yourself and potentially to leap out of the living you're making and you know,
really hit it big,
you're unlikely to do that in academia.
Uh,
so there's a,
there's a sort of a risk aversion I think,
um,
to the prospect of making it big financially that academics tend to have,
that may be,
may,
maybe conservatives would be less likely to,
to go that way.
Do you think he could also be,
the conservatives were just self selecting out,
like they realize the hostile atmosphere,
so they were just like,
why would I do this?
Absolutely.
That is one of the explanations for sure.
And,
um,
you know,
certainly in some fields,
an engineered,
the,
the less human focused the field,
the more conservatives there are.
We know this.
So in engineering,
for instance,
in the more physical sciences,
mostly people don't speak their politics on college campuses if they are on the
right because they're not welcome there.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but those fields do have higher representations of conservatives than liberals,
but most of the social sciences and humanities,
uh,
we're all always tended liberal but are even more so.
I don't remember the numbers off the top of my head,
but even more so now than they ever have been.
And that's a problem to have,
you know,
take,
to have a field that is trying to understand the nature of humans,
you know,
any of the social sciences,
psychology or anthropology or sociology to be entirely limited to people on the
left side of the political spectrum.
Maybe you're missing something in your explanation of what humans are.
If you don't have anyone who's willing to speak to a different political
position.
So when I've talked to Jordan Peterson,
who you referenced and my friend Peter,
but goes in in a couple of other people who are professors,
um,
you probably know Pete,
right?
Yep.
Yeah.
Um,
I think a lot of their argument is based around that,
you know,
the gender studies and these sort of,
these sort of new fields basically have a completely separate set of standards
that have been,
have virtually nothing to do with any of the standards that you as an
evolutionary biologist had to had two and half to uh,
prescribe to,
to do your work.
Is that really the crux of it?
Sort of at the institutional level.
I schools I,
that is at least one of the Foa Psi that,
that I have seen as well,
that there are many new fields,
many of which end in the word studies,
uh,
like gender studies that are frankly,
they're,
they're made up,
they are based in postmodernism and not just not just postmodernism because at
its base originally there,
there's some stuff of value there,
believe it or not,
but the,
the new manifestations in critical theory and such are,
are basically free of any fact checking apparatus.
So they are,
they are anti science,
anti enlightenment and,
and they're quite willing to say things like reason is a tool.
The Patriarchs,
this is the new one.
This one started popping up in the last six months.
Right.
And I mean you,
you just have to know you're dealing with people who are not going to be playing
in good faith and willing to have an actually,
you know,
viable argument at the point that they say that.
Uh,
so it's that there has been capture,
you know,
pretty pretty solid capture and a few of them more traditional fields.
I'm not entirely,
in fact,
I met several people at Heterodox,
um,
who are sociologists who are fighting this from within,
but sociology is one of the captured fields,
anthropology,
geography and um,
or cultural anthropology in particular.
So that the fact that it is that there are fields that students can go into and
basically never be exposed to the idea of you're going to generate as many
possible explanations for the thing that you've observed as possible.
We're going to do hypothesis generation first and then we're going to try to
figure out what would it have to be true if any,
if each of those individual hypotheses were true.
And then we're going to try to figure out how to test between them.
That's the scientific method and it's,
it's an efficient,
it sometimes gets things wrong,
but it is the only tool we have to over time get to a better and better
understanding of the universe.
And there's,
there's no,
there's a method over in gender studies.
Yeah.
So how have you seen that way of thinking leak into the harder sciences?
Cause this seems to be the next frontier here.
Yeah.
Um,
there are,
there are some schools now that when positions come open in,
um,
in science disciplines.
So most schools,
this wasn't true what evergreen,
but at most schools through the hiring apparatuses within,
uh,
within department.
So you have someone in physics,
retires and physics gets to society,
the Physics Faculty and Department Chair and such get to decide what kind of
physicists they're going to hire next.
Somehow.
Increasingly,
science educators are being,
uh,
being hired rather than scientists themselves.
And science educator is a code word for people coming out of Ed schools and
education schools have,
have this pathogen very,
very badly.
So,
um,
science educators being hired into positions that should have been scientists
means that now you have a weakening of scientific voice and scientific method in
science departments.
You have a,
I mean,
even what was that just recently nature I think published one of the two big
science journals,
um,
published,
I don't know if it was a letter or an article arguing that one of the primary
things that science needs to be focusing on is increasing diversity.
Okay.
So two problems with this.
What are your measures of diversity?
It's the stuff that you can see on first pass.
It's these immutable characteristics and has nothing to do with actually all the
other kinds of diversity that are interesting and that,
you know,
and,
and that we can change things like political belief and you'll see some things
that we can't change,
but things like being on the autism spectrum or you know,
even like,
you know,
colorblindness or dyslexia or lefthand in this,
all of which provide your brain without us ever being conscious of it.
Some different way of approaching the world and that kind of diversity in a
group of people.
Ads,
ads,
actual intrigue and nuance to conversations.
And then I'm a lefty with a little dyslexia actually.
So there you go.
I'm a lefty too.
All right.
So you know,
lefties,
like,
you know,
like many other members of these groups,
but I happened to,
I happen to know the lefty one because I've done some research on it.
Lefties are overrepresented at,
you know,
in the National Academy of Sciences and the mental institutions.
You've got this really big spread.
Well,
now I can see that there's really two options for your future.
That's right.
Okay.